William Wallace: Scotland's larger-than-life
hero
Thanks to the 1995 Mel Gibson movie Braveheart,
most people are fairly familiar with the name
of William Wallace.
Unfortunately, thanks to the same film, most
people also have a mental picture of him that
varies between mildly inaccurate and completely
wrong.
He was, indeed, one of Scotland's most iconic
freedom fighters… wasn't he?
The truth is fairly difficult to track down,
in large part due to the fact that he lived
in the 13th century.
Records were iffy at best, and doing even
just a little bit of digging uncovers the
fact that some of the original sources for
many of the well-known "facts" about Wallace's
life were viewed as dodgy right from the beginning.
Wallace exists in that strange realm somewhere
between historical fact and oft-told legend,
which means separating fact from fiction can
be tricky at best.
We're going to give it a try.
The misstep of a horse changed the course
of history
In order to truly understand Wallace — and
why he became such a figurehead for Scotland's
national identity — it's important to know
a little bit about the world he lived in.
And this starts with Alexander III.
Alexander III ruled Scotland from 1249 to
1286, after being crowned king at just eight
years old.
That just sounds like a recipe for disaster,
and it nearly was.
While he was still a child, rival factions
within the country struggled for control of
the young king, but when he turned 21, he
made it clear that the crown was very much
his own to do with what he pleased.
And one of the first things he did was to
finish what his father had started.
The islands off the coast of his country were
under Norwegian control, and within just a
few years he had done what his father could
not: he got those islands back into Scottish
control.
Meanwhile, at home, he ushered in something
of a golden age for his nation.
Trade flourished, and Scotland was on good
terms not only with the countries and rulers
of the continent, but of England, too.
The land dedicated to agriculture continued
to sprawl, monasteries and abbeys popped up
across the country, and these centers of religious
learning flourished.
Life was, for the most part, surprisingly
peaceful.
But, like most good things, it wasn't going
to last.
Alexander first married Margaret and tragically,
but she and their two sons were dead by 1283.
They had a daughter, too, who married Norway's
King Eirik II and had a daughter of her own.
That child — Margaret, the Maid of Norway
— was acknowledged as the heir to the throne,
but things often don't go as planned.
The king still wanted a male heir, and ended
up remarrying.
He and Yolande de Dreux, Comtesse de Montfort,
tied the knot in 1285, and for a time, it
looked as though a male heir was possible.
Yolande was pregnant with their first child
when Alexander decided to ride from Edinburgh
to her side at Kinghorn Castle.
He would never finish the journey, and a single
misstep by his horse changed history.
It was dark, the weather was terrible, and
his horse slipped along the cliffside road
near Pettycur.
Alexander fell, and his body was recovered
the following day.
Yolande would ultimately lose their only child,
leaving the little Maid of Norway as the heir
to the Scottish throne.
Six guardians were appointed to watch over
Margaret, who was just eight years old.
Scotland turned to the English monarchy to
help secure her position as their new ruler,
and England agreed.
Their king, Edward I, drew up a treaty that
not only betrothed the little Margaret to
his own son — who would become Edward II
— but also guaranteed Scottish independence.
In 1290, Margaret, the Maid of Norway, left
Bergen and headed to the aptly named St. Margaret's
Hope in South Ronaldsay.
And there, she died.
She passed away after suffering from severe
sea-sickness, and this is where the tale turns.
Had Margaret wed Edward II, Scotland and England
would have been united — peacefully.
Instead, Scotland was left with no immediate
ruler and now, England had a claim to stake.
The Wars of Independence and a mysterious
hero
Now, historians pretty much agree that everything
we just talked about happened like we said.
But when it comes to Wallace, things are a
little murky.
He had already been born by the time Scotland
was plunged into the kind of chaos that only
comes when an entire nation is left without
a clear plan for succession, but there's no
consensus on even the basics, like when and
where he was born.
The closest historians have been able to get
is somewhere around 1270, with both Elderslie
and Ellerslie laying claim to the honor of
being his birthplace.
While Wallace definitely wasn't a nobleman,
he wasn't exactly a peasant, either.
His father was a knight and a minor landowner,
and interestingly, he was likely from a family
of fairly recent immigrants to Scotland.
His family name, Wallace, comes from "le Waleis",
which means "the Welshman".
It's thought that he was a descendent of a
Richard Wallace who had moved to Scotland
alongside the Stewarts only in the 12th century.
What else do we know about his early years?
Not much.
He was well educated, knew both French and
Latin, and that was likely thanks to tutelage
from his uncle, who was a priest at Dunipace.
Given his later successes on the battlefield,
historians have surmised that he had military
experience before his rise as a revolutionary,
and it's even been suggested that he fought
for Edward I in various Welsh campaigns.
It's also thought that Wallace had run-ins
with the law well before he answered the call
of the revolutionaries.
It's even possible that he was known more
as an outlaw than any kind of upstanding knight.
Wallace took the education that his uncle
had begun and headed to Dundee to finish it.
According to one story, that's where he killed
the son of an English constable who had insulted
him.
It's also believed that he killed several
English soldiers in Ayrshire after they confronted
him for illegal fishing, and it wasn't until
1297 that he became something more than a
common miscreant.
And this is where we're going to take a moment
for a very important aside.
There are only a few instances where a reliable
source recorded information about Wallace,
and most of those have to do with his two
most famous battles, Falkirk and Stirling
Bridge, and — spoiler alert — his execution.
Aside from that, sources are a little iffy.
In fact, the major source of information on
Wallace's life is a poet named Henry the Minstrel,
who was better known as Blind Harry.
He was born around 1440, and that means he
wrote his epic poem, The Wallace, a full century
and a half after the real Wallace's death.
And here's where things get even more complicated.
Blind Harry — who was, indeed, blind from
birth — claimed he wrote his epic based
on the writings of a John Blair.
Blair, he said, was a Benedictine monk who
had been close friends with Wallace and who
had written a biography of him at the request
of a senior bishop.
There's no actual proof this request was ever
made, though, even though it's technically
plausible.
To go one step further, there's no proof that
a biography of Wallace ever existed, either,
but there is a fascinating story that makes
it possible that manuscript had actually been
written.
An early version of Blind Harry's Wallace
poem included text by a monk named Arnold
Blair, not John Blair.
Buried in another manuscript is a title for
that work, supposedly written about the Scottish
hero, along with a footnote that read, "Vide
Cottonian MSS."
And that's surprisingly important.
The Cottonian Manuscripts were given to the
British Museum in 1700 by Sir John Cotton,
and only 31 years later, a fire destroyed
about a quarter of the manuscripts in the
collection.
Was Wallace's biography among them?
We have no idea, and that means it's impossible
to trace many of the details of Wallace's
life back beyond Blind Harry.
As if that isn't confusing enough, there are
plenty of details in Blind Harry's definitive
Wallace work that historians have proved to
be false.
One of the very first assertions Blind Harry
makes is that William Wallace was the son
of Malcolm Wallace.
He wasn't.
In 1297, Wallace wrote a letter to the mayors
of the German towns of Lubeck and Hamburg.
The letter has survived, along with Wallace's
own personal seal.
It shows a hand drawing back the string and
arrow of a bow, and it includes a Latin inscription
that translates to "William, son of Alan Wallace".
That calls into question the historical accuracy
of one of the most famous and oft-repeated
episodes in Wallace's life.
The popularly-told tale is that Wallace had
married a woman named Marion, and was visiting
the lady and their daughter when English soldiers
got wind of his location.
He ran and rallied his own men, but Marion
was executed in the meantime and cemented
his determination to free Scotland from English
rule.
Did it happen?
Maybe, maybe not.
The defiance of John Balliol and Stirling
Bridge
The English king didn't immediately step in
to take over rule of Scotland, and instead,
he first tried to install a king who he was
fairly certain would obey him without question.
That was John Balliol, and in all fairness,
it was the Scottish lords who asked Edward
I to choose a new ruler.
Balliol seemed to fit the bill in that he
was a descendant of former Scottish king David
I, and the English crown also saw him as something
of a weak-willed successor who would remember
who put him in power — and be eternally
grateful for that.
That was in 1290, and things went sideways
very quickly.
England and France were embroiled in conflict,
and Balliol not only refused to support England,
but in 1295 he formed an alliance with France.
That, of course, didn't go over well at all.
The following year, Edward marched into Scotland,
dethroned Balliol, and took over ruling Scotland
directly.
Scottish nobles were imprisoned or found themselves
beholden to their English rulers, and countless
Scottish soldiers were forced to march alongside
the English in their campaigns against the
French.
Revolt came surprisingly fast, and even as
Balliol struggled to reestablish peace through
more conventional means, the rebels believed
they had an advantage.
The English army was fighting France, too,
and that meant they had fewer troops to send
against Scottish rebels.
In 1297, those Scottish rebels kicked off
the First War of Independence at Lanark and
sadly, exactly what happened is unclear.
Even Lanark's official history makes it clear
that no one really knows just why Wallace
chose to gather his supporters at that particular
location, but it is known that Wallace killed
the occupying Sheriff of Lanark — along
with most of his men — and kicked off the
rebellion in full.
This is, of course, where the story about
Wallace's wife and her execution comes into
the tale, but again, some historians believe
they've outright debunked the idea that she
even existed.
Over the next months, Wallace and his rebels
hit targets in Dundee, Ancrum, and Scone.
Other uprisings were led by Andrew Murray
and the MacDougall clan, and on September
11, 1297, things truly came to a head across
the River Forth at Stirling Bridge.
The area presented some unique challenges
to advancing armies, the most famous of which
was very real — the bottleneck that restricted
the advancement of the English army.
After a series of failed negotiations for
peace, the English army — led by the Earl
of Surrey — advanced across the river to
the northern side.
Wallace was already camped there with his
troops and had the benefit of high ground;
he waited until a large portion of the English
calvary had crossed the bridge to charge with
his spearmen, pinning the calvary against
the river and slaughtering them wholesale.
Only some of those that tried to flee actually
escaped the massacre, and it was a decisive
battle that ended with the unraveling of the
Earl of Surrey's coalition army.
Where some Scottish lords had marched alongside
him — including James Stewart, the High
Steward — that changed after Stirling.
Stewart not only pulled his men out of the
English army, but he attacked the fleeing
baggage train to encourage them to leave just
a little bit faster.
Among those the fleeing English army left
behind was Hugh de Cressingham, the Treasurer
of Scotland.
It's impossible to describe just how much
he was hated by the Scottish rebels, and his
fate says it all.
Cressingham was flayed, and some sources say
he was skinned while he was still alive, while
others say he was dead.
Pieces of his skin were distributed among
the victorious as trophies, and the legend
says further that Wallace took a particularly
large piece of skin and turned it into a belt
for his sword.
The events of Stirling Bridge meant that Wallace
was a hero, sitting at the top of the victorious
Scottish army.
Unfortunately
for Wallace, it
was a short-lived victory.
The Guardian of Scotland
After
Wallace
routed the English troops at Stirling Bridge,
he was honored at a ceremony in Kirk o' the
Forest.
Scottish nobles named him Guardian of Scotland,
and this is one bit of the Wallace story that
historians know a lot about.
In 2016, the Scottish Borders Council and
the University of Dunham conducted a geophysics
survey that uncovered the ruins of the medieval
chapel where Wallace would have been honored
hundreds of years ago.
Unfortunately for the Scots, Wallace's triumph
would quickly turn sour.
Edward I was a monarch not about to stand
for the humiliating defeat his troops had
suffered at Stirling, and in 1298 he marched
on Scotland with thousands of calvary, infantry,
and archers armed with one of England's greatest
weapons — the longbow.
And that ended up being Wallace's weakness.
Stirling Bridge may have been a triumph, but
this conflict at Falkirk was a brutal defeat
for Wallace and his rebels.
The English monarch had learned from the mistakes
the military made at Stirling Bridge.
Wallace had favored a technique where he put
his spearmen into a series of groups called
schiltrons, and against calvary, it was a
brilliant and deadly strategy.
Against longbows, it wasn't nearly as effective
and, for the first time, Edward I's longbows
decimated an enemy.
Those that didn't fall to the raining arrows
were sent fleeing by charges from the English
calvary, and although both sides suffered
massive losses, Wallace lost something else
— support.
Wallace retreated to regroup, and for the
next few years, he disappeared from mainstream
history.
The hero who had, not long ago, sent letters
to the other leaders of Europe proclaiming
Scotland's independence from England had escaped,
but he also resigned his position as Guardian
of Scotland.
Over the next few years, he travelled abroad
and met with some of those same leaders, hoping
to cement allies for the Scottish cause.
Like the sources for much of Wallace's life,
sources that talk about his time abroad also
vary greatly in the details, but there are
some fascinating tidbits to be gleaned from
them.
An outlaw and a traitor
It's not 100 percent clear just where Wallace
went first, but it's likely his first stop
was Norway.
From there, it seems as though he headed to
France, and a strange thing reportedly happened.
Wallace's trip to France happened at the same
time Edward I was marrying his second wife,
and that was Margaret, sister to France's
Philip IV.
The marriage was, by most accounts, an unconditionally
happy one, and when the young queen was widowed
at just 26 years old, she swore to never remarry
— and didn't.
It also did what it was supposed to — it
brought the two long-time enemies together
just long enough that England could turn her
sights to putting down rebellion in Scotland.
And according to some sources, France's Phillip
IV was on such friendly terms with Edward
I that when Wallace turned up at the French
court — no doubt expecting to find someone
who hated the English as much as he did — he
was actually arrested.
Philip offered to hand Wallace over to the
English crown, but strangely, he was just
thanked for the gesture and asked to keep
Wallace there.
For safekeeping?
Perhaps, but if there's anything history has
taught us it's that England and France just
can't seem to stay on the same side for long.
Within the year, Wallace had gotten back into
the good graces of the French king.
Not only was he released, but historians believe
they knew where he had planned on going next
to plead his case for Scottish independence:
Rome.
But here's where things get slightly complicated,
and it's also the perfect example of just
how little we really know about Scotland's
largest hero.
It's going to take a little bit of fast-forwarding,
all the way to 2011.
At the time, there was a letter sitting in
the National Archives in London, and it was
said to be a safe conduct letter written by
Philip IV and addressed to the Pope.
The letter confirmed Wallace's high standing
with the court of France, and asked the Pope
to consider that when he was deciding whether
or not to hear Wallace's case.
There were two theories as to the provenance
of the letter.
One suggested it had been taken from Wallace
when he was arrested by English forces in
1305, while another suggested it had been
carried by someone else entirely and intercepted
by spies.
The letter was given to the National Records
of Scotland under a long-term loan agreement,
but there's still a lot of mystery surrounding
it.
There's no evidence to suggest Wallace ever
made it to Rome, and when it comes to the
question of whether or not he was carrying
the letter when he was arrested, the closest
experts have been able to get to an answer
is "probably?".
And that's surprising.
Wallace is this important, larger-than-life
figure that represents Scottish independence,
but when it comes to concrete facts and artifacts,
there's just not that much there.
This letter — along with the letter to Lubeck
we mentioned earlier — is it, as far as
Wallace documents go.
That said, we're getting to the end of Wallace's
tale.
And, it's not a happy ending.
Some accounts suggest that around 1303, Edward
I offered Wallace the chance to surrender
and pledge his loyalty to the English crown
— several times, in fact.
Wallace refused, and even that's up for historical
debate.
The sources that claim clemency was offered
are English so… it's unclear just what the
truth is.
It's not known exactly when he returned to
Scotland from traveling to Europe, but we
do know he was showing up in skirmishes across
the countryside in 1303.
After his refusal to bend the knee to England
and Edward I, Wallace was officially declared
a traitor to the crown and an outlaw.
The declaration was a powerful one, and it
meant it was open season on him.
Anyone could kill him without mercy or feeling
the least bit guilty, and on the same note,
giving him aid or safe passage was considered
treason.
It wasn't long before he was captured and
handed over to the English, by a fellow Scotsman
named Sir John Menteith.
And this is where we can say, without a doubt,
that we definitely know exactly what happened
to Wallace.
He was executed in London's Smithfield area
on Monday, the 23rd of August, 1305.
We know because the event — the spectacle,
even — was recorded by numerous monastic
chroniclers, and for the most part, their
testimony was the same.
The execution itself was a long, gruesome
affair, but there was a method to the madness.
The punishments were handed out to fit the
crimes he had been found guilty of, and first
was the crime of treason.
As punishment, horses dragged him through
the streets of London to the site of his execution.
Next was the punishment for murder and robbery,
and that was to be hanged until not quite
dead.
He was cut down, and then suffered his punishment
for the desecration of churches: he was castrated
and disemboweled, his organs set on fire in
front of him.
Whether or not he was aware of what was going
on, sources are vague — they do seem to
agree that when he was cut down from the gallows,
he was still very much alive.
Lastly was the punishment for being named
an outlaw: beheading.
His head was mounted on London Bridge, and
what was left of the rest of his body was
cut into four parts and displayed in Newcastle-upon-Tyne,
Berwick-upon-Tweed, Perth, and Stirling.
When we call the entire thing a spectacle,
it really was.
His execution marked the opening of the Bartholomew
Fair, which was one of the largest communal
gatherings in 14th century England.
There's a bit of irony here, too, in that
Saint Bartholomew was both the patron saint
of butchers and of tanners.
Was Edward I making a statement, bringing
an end to Wallace's rebellion on the day dedicated
to the patron saint of butchers?
It is, of course, impossible to say for sure,
but… some food for thought.
Saint Bartholomew's apocryphal literature
has him learning the secret cosmic knowledge
from the divine, bringing together goats,
leopards, and even a werewolf in peace.
Wallace reportedly skinned Hugh de Cressingham
and wore his hide as a belt long before he
was beheaded by the English king, and Saint
Bartholomew was both skinned and beheaded
before being dismembered and having his remains
scattered to the four winds.
Much like Bartholomew became one of Christendom's
most tormented martyrs, Wallace became an
even more important figure for Scottish resistance
after his execution, and remained so for hundreds
of years.